[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سأسردها بإيجاز وهناك أحداث بالفعل
الحمير في الفنادق في مرافق الاستقبال ابتداء من المدخل
أخبرنا الناس أن هذا ليس إرثًا لمرافق الاستقبال
من بين الموظفين، أولئك الذين يريدون بعض مرافق الاستقبال
دخل للتو دون أن يعرف من هو وما الذي يمر به
عدم إجراء الفحص الأساسي للعديد من المتطوعين
ويوضع الأطفال تحت شبهة الاعتداء الجنسي
أفترض أن رابطة مراكز المساعدة ستكون قادرة على تقديم التفاصيل
الحالات التي وصلت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لهم
[موسيقى]
هكذا سأقول أنهم جاؤوا إلينا كثيرًا
القضايا المتعلقة بتعاطي الكحول والمخدرات
الفتيان والفتيات المراهقات الذين يتجولون فقط
في الفندق في الأماكن العامة لأنهم يصلون أيضًا
لدينا للأسف حالات اعتداء جنسي
التي تحدث تحت تأثير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حب الهال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ر
[موسيقى]